be real
when you're real when you're you when
you say what's on your mind when you let
people into your life a little bit
they'll like you more they'll trust you
more they'll want to do business with
you more because you are a person
right nobody likes dealing with
companies but they love dealing with
people so you have to inject more of
yourself
into your business and be real i got a
great response from
an email i won't say the guy's name so
i'm going to call him d
and i had a interview set up with dee he
wanted to interview me
on my site
and come time the interview time is here
i'm on my computer i'm ready to go i've
loaded up my google plus and and he's
missing
no email i ping him no message i waited
five minutes i have a five minute rule
you don't show up in five minutes i'm
gone
and i moved on with the rest of my day
and i wrote to him say hey were we not
on for whatever 10 30 this morning
and he wrote back with a really personal
real response
okay here's part of what he wrote back
hey evan listen i'm so sorry about not
showing i know that's really bad
i'm just going to be honest and say i
had a fight with my girlfriend who's now
flying in italy for two weeks was really
uncharacteristic of us
this was not the only appointment i
missed something for me to work on i
know i'd still love to interview you it
goes down
hey this is real talk okay he could have
just said i had something come up or i
had a family emergency
right have you ever used that i know
i've used that i said i have a family
emergency and and i have to cancel or
i've missed something because i had a
family emergency
say what the emergency is
this is so much more real than what i
did
when i cancelled on somebody
right now i feel for the guy how do you
not want to reschedule
the meeting how do you not understand
that hey the guy had a relationship
issue his girlfriend left him for two
weeks flying italy whatever it is
that's real talk
i like this guy
he he skipped out on me on my interview
and i like him more
see how that works because he's real
so share yourself not only in the bad
stuff not only when you you miss
meetings but in the good stuff too
inject yourself and what you're thinking
and and real talk into everything you do
with your business
because people do like to buy from
people it's really that simple you like
buying from people who you know like and
trust and it's the same thing for other
people
they want to know you
so be honest
even if it doesn't look good right this
does not make him look good which is why
i didn't want to say his full name
but it was real and it's authentic and
it drives me to him more i feel like i
know him better i'm closer to him and
the next time he emails i'm going to
respond
faster than somebody else who i don't
feel a strong connection to and i've
never met the guy in my life
so that's the power of be real
it's time for you to step up
be real
believe
if you guys liked the video
thumbs up below
and i want to hear you have to think
please leave a comment underneath let me
know your thoughts if you have a
question put it below i'll do a video
response i really love seeing your
comments come in thank you guys i'll see
you soon